boiled eggs with a soldier that will
make your taste buds stand to attention
there's something quite nostalgic about
a bald egg it's something that's never
lost it's magic when you slice that top
off and dunk that Soldier into the yolk
you can't mess with a deliciously runny
yolk but this is what I like to dunk in
it an anchovy Soldier anchovies
interperson water no salt naturally yeah
anchovies are very salty so just a touch
of pepper
rich in Omega-3s the amazing tinned
anchovy is a natural flavor enhancer and
I use it to Pepper many a Savory dish
from roast lamb to the humble toasted
Soldier
grind them
it's a really nice smooth paste the
smell of that is almost like being on
the seaside now get your soft butter
I just put half the butter in first 50
50 is the way 50 anchovy 50 butter that
way you've got that real nice salty
creaminess mix that up
it's absolutely delicious trust me
finishing that anchovy butter on a slice
of grilled fish I'm in heaven the bread
this is a Sourdough
delicious very crusty take four nice
slices
now get that pan nice and hot
a couple of tablespoons of that anchovy
oil into the pan and then get your bread
and lightly fry each side
the smell and the anchovy oil is
incredible
take that out
now bring your water up to the boil The
Secret of softly boiling an egg is to
place them into the water gently on a
spoon in and just tilt so they don't hit
the bottom nice and Light
up to the ball count to five turn the
gas down is it four and a half minutes
is it five minutes for soft boiled egg
I've cooked thousands of them and every
time
four and a half minutes whilst that's
boiling get your bread
spread that on there that is incredible
chopped parsley brings that kind of
freshness
goes brilliantly well with the anchovies
feel that crunch
on
inside but I can't resist
oh my God
right
gas off one
Beauty in
two
I feel like a five-year-old again
this is that moment when you open the
vault and that little magic inside is
all yours
there's a great Twist on a great classic
wow
[Music]
perfectly soft boiled eggs with dressed
up anchovy butter soldiers
i've smoked haddock and spinach baked
eggs
spoke haddock one of my favorite fish
delicious
highly sustainable it's packed with
protein lightly smoked there's not a Dye
smoke there's a big difference so you
haven't got that bright yellow tinge so
much better
next baby spinach there's a spinach
that's very young full of zinc great
flavor a little teaspoon volleyball knob
of butter
that little touch of oil stops the
butter from burning
it looks like a lot of spinach
I was going to disintegrate almost by
two-thirds I'm cooking spinach and
butter open up the top of my pepper
Mills so the pepper becomes almost like
so Cracked Pepper not so fine
once your spinach has reduced down by
two-thirds add in your cubes of smoked
haddock
it's got that nice vinegary flavor quite
tart pick off the little buds from the
stalks keep hold of these and grateful
when you're making a target of vinegar
red wine vinegar tag and stalks in
chop the target into your creme fraiche
little season
now grain mustard goes brilliantly well
with haddock
incredible this mustardy Herby creme
fresh will work equally well partnered
with grilled chicken
the haddock's starting to flake because
it's smoked lightly cured it Cooks so
quickly you creme fresh
now it's almost like the beginning of
the perfect fish pie but as opposed to
putting pastry on top the eggs are going
to bake on top so you've got this
wonderful egg crust
turn the gas off
now
crack your eggs around the outside
just a little twist of pepper get the
remainder of your creme fresh and put a
little dollop
in between that adds richness to the egg
whites into the oven at 180.
for 10 to 12 minutes
[Music]
whilst the haddock and eggs baked
together I can knock up a simple spring
onion garnish
in professional kitchen chefs refuse to
use the top of the spring onions but I
love that nice dark green flavor it says
harsh and the white the smell of baked
mustard you can't beat
[Music]
that is beautiful
spinach has almost melted in with a had
it now just sprinkle your spring onions
that gives that really nice sharpness
My ultimate hearty breakfast smoked
haddock and spinach baked eggs so packed
with protein and iron you'll be raring
to dive into the day ahead
[Music]
of eggs benedict with Crispy Parma ham
the secret behind a great egg Benedict
is in the hollandaise so get your pan on
because I'm going to cook a hollandaise
over a rolling boil with a glass bowl
butter just put it on to melt
three egg yolks
separated from the white
targon vinegar pop that into the eggs if
you can't get tarot and vinegar any
white wine vinegar will do just as long
as you've got that acidity in there give
some bite to the hollandaise put your
bowl
over the Rolling Water
and just start whisking
if the eggs had Direct contact with the
gas pollen days will become scrambled
egg
once you've got that nice creamy texture
a nice thick Sauvignon start adding your
butter
nice and slowly
a couple of tablespoons of butter in and
give that a really nice mix
if you don't whisk it enough the egg
yolks don't take the butter it causes it
to split it's more butter
using a big balloon whisk like this one
makes it easier to incorporate air and
helps prevent your mixture from
separating all the butter in
the best way to keep hollandaise nice
and warm is just leave it to sit over
that nice warm water bath and it just
gives it a really nice room temperature
a nice pinch of salt
fresh pepper and then face lemon juice
that just really makes it vibrant
exciting
and you want it like a sort of thick
custard I just want it to coat the back
of the spoon so it's like you're giving
the a nice glossy texture to your
beautiful poached egg now as the base
for the eggs benedict you cannot beat
English muffins but the ham
I'm Gonna Change I'm going to use the
most amazing Parma ham get your pan nice
and hot into the pan
it's like Posh rashes of bacon
beautiful
[Music]
ham fried nice and crisp like that is
incredible beautifully salads fantastic
for eggs Benedict
[Music]
now keep that pan nice and hot
I want all that flavor on the Parma ham
left in there and rather than toast my
muffins I want to put the muffins into
the pan I want them sucking up all that
wonderful flavor from that crispy Parma
ham
make sure your muffins are toasted
nicely this will prevent them going
soggy later look at that nice and crisp
that water on to boil for the eggs
nicely seasoned really important and
then just a little splash of vinegar in
the water that helps to set the egg
white in a minute you crack it in
while the water heats up in the pan
there's time to get organized lay a nice
slice of ham on the base
now water's brought up to the ball turn
it down and then spin your water around
like a little whirlpool
and get a little cup so you just drop
the cup in
gets caught up in the turbulence of the
water
the secret is not to boil the water
rapidly because the strength of the ball
can literally explode your egg as they
start to move the way up to the top of
the water that's a indication that
they're cooked take off any excess
little bits of egg white
and then out onto a piece of tissue
paper that just drains off excess water
and it stops your muffin from going
really soggy
but look they're like little beautiful
mozzarella balls give them a little
season
lift them on to a crispy Parma ham
peaceful
now get a nice spoon of your Hollandaise
glaze over
try and do it in one glazing over the
whole egg
when I tell Jack Holly and Megan I'm
Matilda that we're cooking eggs benedict
for breakfast they bolt down the stairs
and let's be honest who wouldn't run to
sit in front of those
[Music]
a special occasion breakfast that would
make anyone feel spoiled eggs benedict
with Crispy Parma ham
foreign